[Music]
you won't see Vin Diesel in her latest
movie either no but you do get to hear
all right IRA loved it he of course is
the voice of baby Groot in guardians of
the galaxy sequel and not having to
appear on screen man it definitely has
its advantages we see Chris Pratt
working out like crazy and eating on I
mean it's got to be a little bit of a
break from all of you little bit of a
break you don't have to worry about the
washboard abs tomorrow instead VIN can
hit the pizza and burners knowing that
all he has to contribute to guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 is his enthusiasm his
voice and those three little words
uh-huh that's right conquer no it's so
good because this is the one that I can
take the kids to they want a lot when I
did the pacifier and they can't see
Riddick they can't see fast I can't see
all these movies cuz they're still too
young I can see God yeah you are such an
angel
he says plane Groot has created
teachable moments for history kids smell
J Vinson and Pauline it gave my kids an
opportunity over dinner to discuss the
word sacrifice and how he could apply to
everything in our lives because
ultimately in a group sacrifices himself
for his family by the way there was very
little audio processing to Vince baby
Groot voice
[Music]
turns out since he was a kid
he's been imitating cartoons what do you
mean I mean it's funny coming out of
this you know what I mean later this got
jacked at all got a big thing coming
when you push me around
[Music]
you